let's get started right away where are
you I am in my dad's office in st. Louis
Missouri I have lived here not in the
office but I've lived at my in my
childhood home since since this started
honestly you the last time I was on your
show was the last time I did anything
you were the last person I think I
touched and it's true Nicky you were the
last person I touched and I'm married
that's just a peek into my life
seriously it's we my parents and I were
just talking about it and they were at
your show with me they were out in LA
visiting me when this all went down it
was right before things got weird and my
mom just revealed to us a couple days
ago that she had been terrified that she
gave you coronavirus because you guys
hugged and it was still in that weird
phase of like do we touch but you you
hugged her and um and so she was
harboring this like deep fear and we
would we were watching your show every
night and she always has this like
awkwardness about it when she's watching
when you clear your throat she's like on
edge like did I give it to him yeah so
she thinks she's out of the woods now so
yeah yeah yeah I think she's safe now I
remember your parents are very nice
people but I remember your mom licking
the side of my face longlegs up both
sides and then she said you're a tasty
man and growl I thought she has issues
but I was very because you are always on
the go and you your career is red-hot
you bet you were on a national tour you
have TV shows and the works and then
suddenly everything stops and this is
true for a lot of people yeah but
everything stops and suddenly on your
parents home in st. Louis that's gotta
be it's going to be like whiplash it
just suddenly stops for you
it was um it's I never thought this
could happen in fact um I've lost every
job I had before this like they've all
kind of stopped or been put on hold
except
one show that I'm writing right now that
I pitched a year ago which was a show in
which I lose everything because I get
cancelled and I have to move back home
to st. Louis to live with my parents and
that's the only show that is still like
going through I have to go through with
so I'm currently writing that show which
used to be some like kind of sci-fi
thing like how could that ever happen
and I'm writing this show now living
here and it's uh um it's weird cuz I'll
write a scene and then I'll go to get
water in the kitchen and like have just
like an attitude with my dad because I'm
like an act one you were just such a
jerk so it's just it was never mind this
would never have happened for me to
learn at home with my parents and it's
um it's just hard because I'm just used
to going out every night and doing
stand-up I'm used to just staying so
busy and getting so much attention and
I've just I'm coping with it I got a
karaoke machine which I sing karaoke in
my parents living room every day I sing
about 8 to 12 songs a day like what are
you singing for example I'm just peeling
off and just sing it a couple Taylor
Swift songs maybe a Britney Spears I've
really been digging into that that song
lucky I've been relating to it a lot cuz
it's like it's about a famous girl who
cries at night because nothing's working
out her way and it really it's just it's
my song I'm gonna burn down my gym
pretty soon I'm just going full Brittney
I yeah I've been I've been just trying
to get my parents to film me so I can
put out content and remind people I'm
alive like and they're disappointing me
they can't they can never get the right
angle and they're like we don't like to
film you so I've just been going to my
front porch and getting the security
camera to capture me yes
you know afraid we have the pictures we
have the pictures from your is this your
ring this must be the ring app camera
put these up it's like you are going for
it
yeah I got a remind people I need to
find a husband when I get out of here
this is it's no joke anymore I can't go
through another one of these even if
they can you know they say that it's
gonna come
back in the fall even by then I want
someone to love me and and I need a
partner I can't live with my parents
forever well I used to be on the
celebrity dating app Riya yeah I've
heard about that yeah so as soon as I
landed in st. Louis I powered that up
and was like what celebrities do we have
in st. Louis and there's one guy who
went to high school with Jon Hamm and
there's also a guy school with Jon Hamm
is a celebrity on Riya I'm kidding but
like literally there was no one in st.
Louis that was famous and so I just have
to yeah I have two results of going
through my my old high school yearbooks
just to comb through and look for
potential mates or someone who could
sell me mushrooms now there's so many
people and thinking like that like he
probably has a side gig you've been able
to meet up with anybody in like a
socially distant responsible way yeah I
I went on a my ex-boyfriend just moved
back to town and so I'm like oh that's
the next chapter of this story I guess
so let's do that so I went on a hike
with him like a couple days ago we went
on an air I found it really good to walk
in front of someone who you're trying to
kind of impress because the whole time I
was just clenching my ass cheeks so I
felt like I got a better workout than I
would normally I really did I was like
trying to impress him from behind and
then later on I was like hey I'm sort
it's like oh you were trying so hard to
win him back with your butt so that was
that was good